All right, welcome back, everybody.
I want to introduce you to the latte stage
here in Culver City.
Basically, this is a very small but productive stage
that we assembled specifically
for the purposes of education,
but it's a really nice stage
to kind of go over what's possible, what's capable,
and I'm gonna kind of walk you through
all of those items that we talked about
in the past section.
So, you know, first off,
we talked about the various carts that we have.
This is just to kind of show you an example
of what that cart looks like,
a little bit of a bright light in front of us,
but these carts are very handy.
Again, they're about $5,000,
but on this particular machine,
this is our multi-purpose machine,
and it's also the machine that's helping drive
our GrandMA3 for DMX lighting controls and so forth.
That's the GrandMA3 there,
and we have our multi-purpose machine here.
These machines basically help us with,
you know, not only for the purpose of controlling
the lights via DMX,
but also, you know, to help set up
and prep and prepare content,
which will ultimately be sent over to our control machine.
If we look at the control machine,
that was the machine that,
this is the machine that actually does
most of the heavy lifting.
This machine here is basically,
we have a number of different capabilities here.
Not only is there Unreal Engine over here,
which is setting up for the various scenes and shots
that we're going to be providing,
but we also have access to the Brompton software here,
which can basically be used
for the configuration of the LED wall.
Here we have, at least on our stage,
we have our broadcasting booth.
This is basically where we're using,
you know, to record a lot of this content
and send things out via Zoom
with our Blackmagic ATEM switcher.
And, you know, this facility also comes equipped,
again, with, we have ARRI Skylights.
We have two of them.
We also have our camera.
This camera is the Blackmagic Ursa G2.
It's a Gen 2 camera, super 35 millimeter sensor.
And it's fully decked out with,
oh, we've got an Atomos shotgun video assist monitor.
We have a video assist monitor.
We have ZEISS Compact Prime, three lenses.
This is a 25 millimeter lens.
And this, of course, is the tracking mine on top.
This is the actual device that's utilized
for being tracked within the environment.
Speaking of tracking,
we utilize the OptiTrack system here.
So we have a number of OptiTrack cameras
throughout this entire facility.
We have actually 17 of these tracking cameras
within this environment.
And it's used specifically, of course,
for tracking the camera location and position.
Now, when we look at the actual wall itself,
I mentioned that the wall has 10 LED panels across,
five LED panels down for the main wall,
along with a five by five panel while,
well, actually that one's the fixed right angle wall.
And then we have our 4K television screen
in a vertical format.
Now, if we go behind the wall,
just so that you can see,
this is set up on an individual truss
in which it's laying on the ground,
or, you know, it's on the ground.
It's not being hung from the ceiling
in this particular case.
But all of these individual panels that we have here,
you can see the backside here,
they're all daisy chain and connected together,
not only through power, but also the data connection
that winds up sending the signal
to all the individual panels within this wall.
If we move to the back, just being careful here,
of course, there's the issue of being able
to route all these signals and the motion capture data,
everything is connected.
We need to have a good ethernet router set up.
In addition to these set of devices here,
this is basically our Brompton processor
and the distribution unit.
And it has a local computer to allow it
to be controlled for setup and so forth.
There are a number of different signals
that come into this.
And then I also want to show you a few other machines.
In addition to all of this,
we have some additional machines over here on the side,
room, our classroom environment.
But these machines are also very important.
This machine is motive.
This basically handles all of our motion capture tracking.
And then this machine is used for rendering.
Everything that you saw out on the wall there,
this is what's being displayed here and here.
So this machine is what is equipped
with the high-end Quadro A6000 cards.
And it's what's rendering the content
that actually goes up on the wall.
So there is a HDMI 4K,
or there's a 4K signal that comes out of here.
That's actually a splitter.
So we have something from the monitor from the computer,
but it also sends the signal all the way over
to the Brompton processor,
which is that device right there.
So the LED processor is what is taking that 4K signal
and converting it and sending it to the distribution units,
which you see are on top of it, which is here and here.
These distribution units send the video signal
to all the individual panels, which you're seeing here.
So this pretty much concludes our small,
short tour of the stage.
And I'd like to say thank you for listening.